INFORMATION, NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, APPRECIATE
IT.
>> Sandra: MIRANDA DEVINE, NEW
YORK POST COLUMNNIST AND FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, AND ALSO
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK "LAPTOP FROM
HELL," AND WROTE THE BOOK ABOUT
THIS STORY.
FIRST UP, WHAT IS YOUR REACTION
TO MUSK APPEARING TO EXPOSE EVEN
MORE CENSORSHIP THAT HAPPENED AT
TWITTER AND THESE BLACK LISTS?
>> WELL, ITS CERTAINLY
ILLUMINATING AND HELPFUL TO SEE
WHAT WAS GOING ON BEHIND THE
SCENES AT TWITTER, NO ONE TOOK
THEIR ASSURANCES THEY WERE NOT
SHADOW BANNING SERIOUSLY, BUT
SHOWS THE EXTENT OF THE
CENSORSHIP REGIME AND REALLY HOW
CONCERTED IT WAS.
WHAT WE DON'T YET KNOW IS THE
INVOLVEMENT OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, PARTICULARLY THE
FBI.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL EVER GET
THAT FROM ELON MUSK AND I KIND
OF DON'T BLAME HIM.
HE'S, ALL HIS BUSINESSES, TESLA,
SPACEX, TWITTER, ARE UNDER
THREAT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF IN HIS FIRST
PRESS CONFERENCE AFTER THE
MIDTERMS TOOK AIM AT ELON MUSK.
JANET YELLEN ALSO MADE A THREAT
TO ELON MUSK.
THE E.U. HAS THREATENED HIM AND
ALSO BIDEN, OR DEMOCRAT DONOR
ALLIES IN WALL STREET COULD ALSO
DO HIS BUSINESSES A LOT OF
DAMAGE.
SO I WOULD SEE THIS AS HE'S
SHOWING THE PEOPLE MAKING
THREATS THAT HE HAS A LOT OF
INFORMATION, HE HAS THE CHANNELS
THROUGH THESE TWO INDEPENDENT
JOURNALIST, BARI WEISS AND MATT
TAIBBI TO GET THEM OUT TO THE
PUBLIC AND GET PUBLICITY FOR
THEM, SO BACK OFF OR I'LL LET
OUT THE MOTHER OF ALL BOMBS.
SO, I'M NOT SURE THAT HE'S GOING
TO SHOW US THE FBI
INTERVENTIONS, BUT WE DO KNOW A
LOT ABOUT THAT FROM THE LAWSUIT
THAT'S BEING BROUGHT BY THE
STATE ATTORNEY GENERALS OF
LOUISIANA AND MISSOURI, AND SO
THERE WILL BE MORE INFORMATION
FROM THAT.
BUT I THINK WE ARE SEEING THE
CENSORSHIP OF THE NEW YORK POST
OVER THE HUNTER BIDEN STORIES
BACK BEFORE THE ELECTION IN
OCTOBER OF 2020, THAT IS JUST
ONE PART OF THE CENSORSHIP
REGIME THAT WAS GOING ON.
ANY KIND OF DISSENT AGAINST THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WHETHER IT
WAS OVER COVID MANDATE,
VACCINES, LOCKDOWNS, MASKS, THE
CDC, AND EVEN CRITICISM OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OVER THEIR
BOTCHED WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
ALL OF THOSE DISSENTING VOICES
WERE SUPPRESSED AND SILENCED.
>> Sandra: WITH THE TIME THAT WE
HAVE LEFT, I JUST GOT REACTION
FROM JAMES COMER, OBVIOUSLY HE
IS THE MAN IN THE HOUSE WHO IS
GOING TO LEAD THE INVESTIGATION
INTO HUNTER BIDEN AS HE PUT IT,
AN INVESTIGATION INTO JOE BIDEN
THROUGH HUNTER BIDEN, AND HE
SAID HE HAS THIS QUESTION.
LISTEN.
>> FROM A BIDEN FAMILY INFLUENCE
PEDDLING PERSPECTIVE, WHY WAS
JOE BIDEN SO INTERESTED IN
BANNING THIS STORY.
WHY DID THE FBI SEEM SO
INTERESTED IN THIS STORY AND I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO ANSWER A
LOT OF QUESTIONS WE HAVE MOVING
FORWARD AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THIS ADMINISTRATION TRULY IS
COMPROMISED.
>> Sandra: HE HAS MADE THIS
POINT MANY TIMES AND NOW HE IS
THE HEAD OF THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE AND PLANS TO GO IN
THIS DIRECTION IN THE NEW YEAR,
MIRANDA.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT HIS
INVESTIGATION WILL REVEAL?
LOOK, I THINK THAT JAMES COMER
HAS A LOT OF GOOD MATERIAL, HE
HAS A LOT OF GOOD INVESTIGATORS.
THEY ARE HOT ON THE TRAIL OF JOE
BIDEN AS THEY SAY, THIS IS NOT
ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN, IT IS ABOUT
JOE BIDEN.
WHAT MONEY AND BENEFITS DID HE
RECEIVE FROM HIS FAMILY'S
INFLUENCE PEDDLING SCHEME.
I THINK THEY WILL FOLLOW THE
MONEY TRAIL THERE, AS WELL AS
ANY COMPROMISE PARTICULARLY WHEN
IT COMES